Thank you to GiveWell, an organization that
makes it easy to find excellent charities
to trust, for sponsoring today’s episode!
GiveWell is matching donations from first-time
donors, dollar for dollar, up to $250.
Click on my link below to donate and be sure
to use the fundraiser code MICROCOSMOS at
checkout to make sure your donation gets matched.
We here at Journey to the Microcosmos have
been very excited for everyone who has ordered
their very own Journey to the Microcosmos
microscope and started their own explorations.
And we love seeing the photos and videos you’ve
shared with us on Twitter of all of the rotifers
and nematodes that you’ve been finding already.
Back before these microscopes were available
to buy though, my trusty co-host Hank took
a demo out for a spin and saw a lot of…this
floating around in the water.
And as any of us would do if we had an expert
in our contacts, Hank decided to turn to our
master of microscopes James for help identifying
these hairy lima beans.
And James replied with the following warning:
“ they are ostracods and they will eat everything
in your sample and poop all the time, until
there is nothing left in your sample but a
bunch of ostracods swimming in their poop.”
Ostracods are a crustacean, encompassing tens
of thousands of species and whose bodies mostly
range from around 0.2 to 2 millimeters in
length.
And thankfully, their size makes them large
enough for James to filter out using a simple
tea infuser, which is how he prevents these
animals from turning his samples into a toilet.
But their size is not just a useful feature
for filtering.
It’s also a clue into a much more fundamental
question about the trade-offs between sexual
reproduction and survival.
To explain what that means, we need to establish
two things.
The first is that if you’re looking at a
male ostracod, you are essentially looking
at a crawling shelled penis.
Do you remember how we said earlier that the
ostracod usually range from around .2-2 mm in length?
Well, for male ostracods, about a third of
that length is made up of penis—or rather
two hemipenes, which make up what ostracod
scientists have called “the large, muscular sperm pump.”
The two hemipenes in the males correspond
to the two openings on the female ostracod,
which hold several dozen eggs ready for fertilization.
And these eggs can have different fathers,
so male ostracods compete with each other
in part by having their large, muscular sperm
pump actually pump out large sperm.
And when I say “large,” I don’t just
mean “large for such a tiny animal.”
Ostracods produce some of the largest sperm
in the animal kingdom...sometimes up to 10
millimeters in length, which is around 182
times longer than human sperm.
The second thing that we need to establish
is that ostracods are remarkably well-preserved.
Their bodies are protected by two shells connected
at a hinge, which shelters their soft bodies
in life and secures their remains in death.
There are ostracod fossils dating back at
least 450 million years.
And in their many hundreds of millions of
years, they have spread to so many waters
and been so well-preserved that their fossils
tell us stories of how the world’s climate
has changed over that long period and how
this little crustacean has adapted in response.
But in addition to their geological storytelling,
ostracod fossils have a few other very notable distinctions.
One distinction is that the oldest fossilized
animal penis we have found belongs to an ostracod,
one that existed around 425 million years
ago.
The species was named Colymbosathon ecplecticos,
which translates to “astounding swimmer
with a large penis.”
Another distinction is that the oldest fossilized
sperm belongs to—yes, you guessed it—the
ostracod.
The remains were found in an Australian bat
cave, where the phosphorus from many years
worth of bat poop ensured that the soft insides
of the ostracod would remain frozen in time.
Scientists even found a female ostracod whose
remains held post-coital sperm.
And these simple facts about the ostracod
may paint a somewhat absurd image of ancient
crustacean genitalia.
But within that absurd image is also a profound
question: is it worth it?
Is it worth the exceptional amount of space
and energy that the male ostracod devotes to reproduction?
To ensuring that its sperm will outcompete
all others?
The animal kingdom is full of examples of
this seemingly simple question.
Think of the peacock, whose ornate train is
exquisitely crafted to attract the comparatively drab peahen.
The ostracod’s equivalent is its size: the
longer the male ostracod, the more it has
invested in its reproductive needs.
And in general male ostracods are longer than
their female counterparts.
The accumulation of these kinds of differences
is called sexual dimorphism.
The higher the degree of dimorphism, the more
different the male and female of a species are.
Some animals have high dimorphism, some have
low.
And so on both ends, the question remains:
is it worth it?
On the one hand, for species with high sexual
dimorphism, the energy an individual might
spend ensuring it stands out from other potential
mates is energy that goes towards a biological
legacy, one that hopefully aids the species
overall.
But that is also energy that potentially comes
at the cost of other essential elements of
an animal’s survival or makes them vulnerable,
leading eventually to their extinction.
It can be difficult to untangle this balance
with animals we see today, whose present day
survival at the very least means their choices
haven’t led to extinction…yet.
But consider the ostracod.
This is a remarkably well-preserved animal with a long history of investment in sexual reproduction.
And over that long history, many species of
ostracod have gone extinct, their beginnings
and ends documented in the fossil record.
So in 2018, researchers studied 93 extinct
ostracod species that lived in the Mississippi
area around 66-84 million years ago.
They turned to the fossil record to quantify
the differences in size and shape between
male and female ostracods of each species,
as well as to measure how long it took for
each species to go extinct.
They found that when males were larger than
females—meaning that they invested more
energy in sexual reproduction—those species
tended to go extinct 10 times faster than
species where the males were smaller.
We’re talking about the ability to survive
as a species for 1.6 million years versus
15.5 million years.
So when it comes to the original question
“is it worth it?” this result seems like
a resounding “no.”
For the ostracod, the compulsion to invest
in sexual reproduction at the individual level
seems to come at a cost to the species overall.
But this is one very specific context, with
one very specific animal and its one very
specific sexual dimorphism.
The story of survival and reproduction is
more than just any one animal, and the question
of “is it worth it?” has only living answers
told across past, present, and future.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We’d also like to thank GiveWell for sponsoring
this episode.
GiveWell makes it easy to find excellent charities
to trust.
They spend over 20,000 hours each year doing
intensive research on charities and all of
that research is available for anyone to view
on their website.
GiveWell emphasizes donating to charities
that have evidence of improving people’s
lives like the Against Malaria Foundation
which provides nets for people to sleep under
so they are not bitten by malaria-carrying
mosquitoes.
Or you could donate to their Maximum Impact
Fund which directs donations to the charities
that GiveWell has determined to be the most
effective each quarter.
GiveWill is here to give you the confidence
that your donations are being used effectively,
and you have the option to do a one-time donation
or set up recurring donations.
Givewell is free to use and does not take
fees from those donations and they are all
tax deductible in the US.
And right now, GiveWell is matching donations
from first-time donors, dollar for dollar,
up to $250.
Click on my link below to donate and be sure
to use the fundraiser code MICROCOSMOS at
checkout to make sure your donation gets matched.
The folks you’re seeing on the screen right
now.
They are people who have supported us on Patreon.
Patreon is a place where you can go and give
a little bit of money to the things that you
really think should exist in the world, and
all of these people really think that Journey
to the Microcosmos should exist.
And we agree with them and we’re so thankful
to them.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, hey,
there’s always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.